joining me today is a kind and hilarious
comedian
currently he's on the showtime series
black monday
please welcome paul scheer how are you
i'm doing good i'm so excited to be here
oh my gosh i'm so by the way
your backdrop is jaw drop jack
look drew i'm gonna come correct i mean
i'm coming on your show i got to step it
up here right this is not i'm not
messing around
well shall we get into the news i'm so
excited yes we got a bunch of good
stories
the feel good week i feel like all right
well huffpost
just published this article surveying
parents
on 35 different names that kids give
everyday things and it's full of terms
that kids just make up because they
don't know or can't pronounce a
difficult word
and honestly some of these terms are
definitely better than the originals
so i love these one parent shared that
their kid calls
pants leg prisons
another politely informed their mom that
women carrying
babies they carry them in their universe
i like that i like that i know it's
really deep
another kid called lasagna spaghetti
cake you know
it actually is the perfect name for it
and it makes me want lasagna more like i
don't know if i like lasagna as much as
i like spaghetti cake all right
well paul you had a story about some
unique holiday fashion
yes all right so one of my favorite
magazines uh cosmo magazine
ran this feature about
holiday sweaters for a pet in your life
that you might not always think needs a
holiday sweater
and this is uh i guess christmas
sweaters for chickens uh you can get
these on
etsy now drew uh you have chickens right
i do in fact i brought some pictures of
my chicken
okay um that is on the left that's
um sparkles the middle is ferdinand
and the right is percy and the one i'm
petting is blanche
and i just love i love these chickens so
much like i'm
way way way too attached to them and i'm
not kidding
i not only want to get them the
christmas sweaters but i'm actually
wondering if there's
like a fashion or also a function
because
sometimes you would put heat lamps in
your
shed for the winter but that makes me
really nervous because it's like a heat
lamp in a wooden shed
and that just seems dangerous so maybe
this way they're going to heat up their
eggs with a nice wool sweater it's
lovely it's great i mean
think about how we feel when we put on a
nice good sweater like that by the way
when chickens are laying their eggs
fun fact they don't move and you can
totally pet them and they just look at
you like
i'm gonna remember that you're doing
this because i can't move
but they're just completely docile and
still
and you can just oh there's this but
this is my question to you these are
sweaters
for chickens drew how are you gonna get
them on
i can barely get a shirt on my dog and
he doesn't move like
try to put a sweater on a chicken that's
like that's rocky level
training right there he's trying to just
chase a chicken like try to get a
sweater on
you know what i'll probably have to wait
until they're laying their eggs
um because again you can almost do
anything to them when they're laying
eggs
including put christmas sweaters on them
how do we know these chickens aren't
jewish
we don't know we don't know we need a we
need a a hanukkah sweater for these guys
as well
you know what we need to clone etsy get
on this this is a giant market so
chicken owners talk to your chickens
find out what's important to them
spiritually and then give them the
appropriate outfits
100 absolutely